you won't find bodies at Titanic you  won't find skeletons the bones actually  dissolve into solution very rapidly at  that depth what anybody who's explored  the wreck finds is pairs of shoes  take some years for a skeleton to vanish  but the shoes treated with tannic acid  they won't eat them so all around the  Titanic part of the shoes  there's a scene where we were filming  and we came across a pair of woman shoes  yeah next to a pair of girls shoes these  were people's were people those shoes  got to the bottom double down on people  they were in their cabin yeah because  the cabin was all around the destruction  of it and there was a hand mirror this  is the human element this is what people  touched it's what they lived with made  [Music]  you